في تونس ازمه اقتصاديه خانقه وخلاف حول
اصلاح المؤسسه العامه ينظر بتاجج التوتر
الاجتماعي جوهر الخلاف بين الحكومه
والاتحاد العام التونسي للشغل بشان حزمه
من الاصلاحات الاقتصاديه يطالب بها
الممولون الدوليون اتحاد الشغل يعارض بعض
الاصلاحات التي تشمل رفع الدعم وخفض كتله
الاجور
وحوكمه المؤسسات العموميه اما الحكومه
فتؤكد انها لن ترفع الدعم وانما ستوجهه
الى مستحقيه وانها لن تبيع المؤسسه العامه
بل ستعيد هيكلتها لانقاذها من الازمه
الماليه الامين العام الاتحاد الشغل نور
الدين الطبوبي انتقد بشده من جانبه
الحكومه في تفاوض على اصلاح المؤسسات
العموميه قائلا انها تتحايا لبيعها وتعيش
البلاد ازمه ماليه خانقه تسببت في ارتفاع
نسبه التضخم الى 9.2% في سبتمبر وفي نقص
المواد الاستهلاك